atlanta georgia is where adam joins us
adam how can we help
hey guys what's going on
got a question for john fellow texan
here but obviously we're down in atlanta
hey we gotta spread the love everywhere
right i'm in nashville so what's what's
up
hey man so second marriage been married
10 years
got two kids with my first wife 16 and
14
and 16 year old has been living with us
for two years now
my wife and i are expecting any day now
and so my 16 year old
is you know we're in we're in family
therapy
and he is extremely jealous
and depressed and and wants to
wants to move out and and move home with
mom you know with the
with the uh introduction of the baby
coming home so
we need some tools that you know can
help us cope with this
and you know some things that obviously
we can
you know give some tools to him as well
but
as of right now i mean he's he's really
tuning everybody out here yeah
so the basically adam the baby's a proxy
what's what's what's beneath that how
long has he been struggling
uh he's been struggling since he moved
with us two years ago
why what precipitated that move why did
he have to move in with you
um expelled from school okay uh
you know alcohol and alcohol and drugs
at you know 11 12 13 years old that
you know nobody nobody knew about and
when it happened he was expelled that
you know so he's 16. he's 16 and does
that mean y'all got
your divorce was when he was about six
five
uh yeah about three about three
yeah divorced in 2007. he was about
three his brother was just over one
years old
okay so when he was three he lived with
mom and went back and forth and back and
forth back and forth
multiple times a year from texas to
michigan okay
so baby's just the latest man he's been
living with
who am i and chaotic systems since
he has any recollection in fact before
he's got recollection his body has
stored this stuff
all over the place this level of trauma
and this level of
dysfunction and so what does your
therapist say when y'all go to family
counseling
what what what what are they
recommending
well you know we're kind of pressing the
therapist now
we'll we'll meet without him and then we
meet with him or he'll meet by himself
but you know we just haven't seen a lot
of progress because he
you know he just repeatedly says that
he's depressed but he never
he never has any clarity to that
yeah 16 year olds man that's asking a
lot of a 16 year old to be
clear to be able to unpack emotions
be able to unpack feelings to be able to
unpack hormones to be able to unpack
this what did i do to cause this this co
this chaos that's been present in my
life the last
5 10 15 years that's a tall order
and so the the impetus falls on the
parents
in these moments to do the connecting
towards the kid do they have to be
accountable for their actions absolutely
do they have to
have good behavior absolutely all they
need those boundaries those are
important
but to sit there and say hey you're
telling me you're depressed
unpack that for me that's a that's hard
for somebody that hasn't been given
those tools over the years
um what is your relationship with him
like one on one y'all are out
walking somewhere y'all going shopping
together you're out fishing together
whatever that looks like
what's your relationship with him like
typically one-on-one it's it's good
um you know we we joke around a lot you
know we
go to the gym and we you know we train
together
uh you know we do stuff here at the
house we do our yard work together
stuff like that our relationship is
is good but it seems like his bond is
shifting more towards mom
here in the past you know six seven
eight nine months it's just increasing
and so it's almost like he he puts on a
persona where everything was fine you
know he's always smiling
and um you know like in good spirits and
excited when he gets home from school
but
you know when he talks to anybody else
you know i'm depressed and
you know things of that nature but and
sometimes
every every teenager is different so i'm
not gonna be able to give you hey you
need to go do this this and this
but i will tell you there are some
situations where teenagers are
will are looking for ways to connect
and if him saying hey i'm depressed
hey i i i'm not doing well is that's
what it takes to get the people who love
him in his life to stop and look them in
the eye and say hey how are we doing
then they'll do that or he's actually
struggling and does not have the words
to put into context how much he's
hurting
my guess is it's been going on a long
long time and he's continuing to look
for different behaviors and so
your right to press your family
therapist you're in the right place i
would be telling you to go do this
um to go find a professional and if
you're not getting some concrete things
that can help heal that relationship
now or to help you connect with him
now then get another therapist find
somebody's going to give you some
practical tips to help heal this
relationship
um and man if if mom's
if mom's a safe place for him to go i
don't have a problem with him going back
to moms if that's where he needs to be
to be successful right now
ken you've got two teenage boys yeah
what's it like trying to get them to
connect their
their their words with their what's
going on in their heart and heads uh
it would be like trying to sandpaper a
bobcats button telephone booth
i don't even know exactly right it's
hard it's tough
it's it's to the point where you they're
only going to tell you what they want to
tell you
um and you know more about this you know
we're learning too that you know
at that age they can't even articulate
that's
is if we think they can because they're
15 or they're 16 and they've got all
kinds of words
but then when they have to actually
confront their emotions and then there's
this
you know what are they going to tell mom
and dad versus what they'll tell friends
and i can tell you from our journey that
we can never
truly predict although we have learned
that there are circumstances
and and moods and ways that we can get
them to a point where they will open up
to us they're still deciding it's not
like we sit down and go tell us
and there's no great technique you know
that um
but it's hard and i think what i was
going to ask you in this situation is i
feel for this this this man
um how do the parents stay healthy and
we're going to break but it may be
something to talk about is
at some point how the parents stay
healthy when their kid's not healthy
that's tough you've got to make that
priority numerous you have to you got to
be okay
with them not being okay that's right
and that doesn't feel very
parental right